Now is the spilling of the cup. So, it's
moving back and forth, I'm trying to
show you like the the movement of the
cup because I think it's overfilling on
the overflowing on the Right there,
yeah.
>> But look, it's going over the edge, but
you're not seeing it spill. If this
video is actually you, then why did you
use a video that's not you with six
fingers? Mhm. Well, I have to be honest,
cuz if you're telling me that's fake,
this is real. Why is that fake? And if
that's fake, how do I know this is not
fake?
This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala tells us in the
Quran a man pleading with Allah to send
him back so he could give [music]
Sadaqah. Why Sadaqah? Because he knows
the weight of Sadaqah. Just 100 [music]
pounds. You can help teach 20 to 60
people to learn how to perform salah,
recite Surah Fatiha, and make wudu.
[music] Click the link and donate now.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh brothers and sisters, dear
friends, as well, inshallah. I know you
guys said you guys don't know about
this, the third day I've been by
Al-Haram and the third Umrah, and you
all are asking good why. But inshallah,
I will finish my Umrah this year, or
maybe I'm going to do an Eid Umrah.
Yeah. Yeah, by 2028, probably.
Hopefully, hopefully. He's been in this
for three days.
>> Yes, inshallah in another couple of
days, inshallah. There's a reason behind
it. It was a bit bad there, but anyways,
we make dua for those out there, Subhana
Wa Ta'ala, who is not married, who are
not married, may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
grant you a righteous wife,
>> Ameen. or a righteous husband. For those
who are ill, may Allah grant you cure.
Ameen. For those who are who cannot have
children, may Allah grant you righteous
children.
>> Ameen. For those, Subhana Wa Ta'ala, who
are lost, may Allah grant you peace.
>> Ameen. And so, for those who are sad,
who have anxiety, depression, may Allah
grant you coolness and steadfastness.
And also, to you, Adhkar. We're going to
watch a video of a a vile vile
individual that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
is going to destroy in this life and the
hereafter.
Well, maybe in the hereafter. So, as you
know, there was a video that was
supposed to show you also recovered, as
well, of him being dead. So, they
speculated he'd be dead, him people not
seeing him, specific meetings that
happened with Mossad or whatever it's
for that matter. He's not there. So,
they're like, why is he not there? So,
he did a video. In that video, they said
that he had six fingers. Six fingers,
yes? So, in this video, he's come out
he's in a coffee shop saying, "Nope,
he's alive." And he's pointing to his
hands. Let's see. And then we're going
to go to a reaction video of someone
dissecting that this could potentially
be AI. But, this video begs more
questions which I'm going to come to.
Let's watch it. Ready?
>> [music]
>> The video cut there.
I don't know what the video cut. I can't
make my much of it. It's just a editing
thing. It could be potentially
I don't know. He's drunk the coffee.
There was
mark is on me. I'll not destroy his
his lips that he drank from. But, I
can't make much of it. It's not really
that deep. But, let's carry on.
>> [music]
>> Okay. So, first impressions, obviously,
what you make of it? To me, subhan
Allah,
that
he's coming out with this. But, the
issue is this. If he's pointing at his
hands and saying, "I've got five
fingers."
Then, the video that was released that
surely shows that that then
that was not you.
If this video is actually you, then why
did you use a video that's not you with
six fingers?
I have to be honest cuz if you're
telling me that's fake, this is real,
why is that fake? And if that's fake,
how do I know this is not fake?
Be because when I see six fingers and
he's like, "Okay, goodbye." He was like,
"Okay, is that me coming to say, 'Okay,
the guy there was a video of me. I had
nine fingers.'"
Look, I don't have nine fingers. Okay,
then why did you do a video with nine
fingers?
Mhm. You get it. I'm kind of split
between two things. Either he's severely
autistic in how he moves or the video's
slightly like You notice his movements
are a little weird. When you watch He
drinks the coffee. You see how fast the
coffee cup moves up, but you don't Like
he moves it pretty fast for the it to
not move very much. It is sus.
>> only that, the the guy we're going to
watch now at 5:30, you're going to see
the coffee doesn't spill. There's a
moment where the moment he picks the
coffee
the coffee should spill. It doesn't
spill. So, the the the issue is that And
not only that, somebody said he's got no
wrinkles at all.
And the whole the whole thing looks a
little like
>> Sus, yes. So, here's a video of an
assessment of this individual saying
this could be potentially AI. Let's
watch it for ourselves. I'm at Skyzone
and I'm watching the Netanyahu video.
It's AI. Shadow, the abs are made a post
and I'm trying to watch the video and I
can't see it, so I threw the Netanyahu
video into Video Leap the editor so you
can go frame-by-frame and I want to walk
you guys through everything I'm seeing.
There's three or four things that I
think will clearly point that this video
is AI. Check this out. So, we're going
to walk through this together. So, what
you guys are watching is I get this in
Video Leap.
We're going to zoom in on the coffee
because they're talking about how full
the cup of coffee is in the
cup of coffee is in the fact that it's
moving and not spilling. And while at
the same time, I want you to pay
attention to the the swirls on the top
of the cup.
>> Okay, do you see that? That's sus. You
see You see You see where he grabs the
coffee? You can see the coffee shaking
and it's
it's it's full to the top, yeah? Okay.
And I'll be honest with you, like I
drink coffee. When you put the lids, if
it's that full, you can't close the lid.
Yeah.
>> And what I'm like baristas, when they
serve it, they don't fill it that much,
bro. Where the froth at the top it's
like if you can't put a lid cuz it would
over spill. You fill it up just
underneath the the the the top bit. So,
they cuz they they Well, they know
people go There's going to be shaking.
They go When you grab the coffee, it's
going to shake. It's going to spill. So,
they never fill it up right to the top.
Do you get it? So, to me that was a bit
like And And you can see that the
movement and it's not spilling. But
here, you can see it clearly see it's
just pretty plain Jane. Yeah, but what
we're looking at here right now is the
spilling of the cup. So, it's moving
back and forth. I'm trying to show you
like the the movement of the cup because
I think it's overfilling on the
overflowing on the Right there, yeah.
>> spilling over the edge. But you're not
seeing it spill, which is pretty crazy,
right?
So, we can go back and forth here. And
again, pay attention to the top of the
cup. I want to show you what you're kind
of seeing on there. Now, it's not
clearly definitive, but as it gets
closer to his mouth, as he comes around
here, the design on the cup is going to
like it like gets better. Like by the
second. Like right now, you're watching
that design. It'll almost be like right
there. See, it switched like instantly
got like almost like perfect there. So,
it's like super clear, super clean. Like
it just came off of a Starbucks cup.
Now, I'm going to try to move this into
position here because we're going to
take a look here. That it might be the
glare of outside that we didn't see it
clearly. I don't know.
Bro, another one is if you look at his
hand
>> Yeah. his this these two fingers right
here look a little weird. Do you hold Do
you hold a cup of coffee like this?
No.
>> So, either he just has severe autism.
It's true. No, no, one second.
I'm just saying I'm just saying I'm just
>> an example.
>> I'm saying. Bro, I hold like this. I
never hold I never hold anything like
this. Look, I never hold like a like a
claw. Like something that is a reptile
or something. And it like looks like
he's
>> bro, look look at the cup. Look look
look at that. On the screen, there's a
gap. Bro, I never ever When I hold
something, I'm holding like this. Or my
coffee, like this. My I'm never holding
like this.
There's weird gap between these two
fingers.
>> Yeah. That's a little That's a little
bit I don't Who grabs coffee like that?
Bro, do you see anyone grabbing coffee
like that?
Bro, you should grab coffee like like
I'm going to I wish I had a cup that I
could show you. Bro, I hold coffee like
this.
Yeah. Take a look here because what
you're going to see is a jump frame. So,
I wanted to see here and I'm just kind
of sliding through here. Now, no normal
camera would ever jump a frame. It's
just not possible. So, what I'm doing is
I'm I'm just scrolling here cuz I'm
trying to see the top of the cup. I'm
trying to look at his teeth. We're going
to take a screenshot and try to compare
like does Netanyahu's teeth actually
look like this? So, that's what I
noticed. I'm like, "Oh, his teeth are
right there. Okay."
And I could probably get a photo of
those teeth. Let's pull it up on full
screen here. Yep.
And then now we're going to take a
screenshot of it. Okay. Now after this
I'm going to catch a jump frame. I'm
just randomly scrolling through here and
all of a sudden it like jumped there.
Like it actually jumped. Like he moved.
Like watch his body move there. You're
going to see it. See? One second he's
there and then the next second it jumps
over.
Like so the the film there is cutting a
frame. That would in real life in a real
video I don't think that it I've never
seen that in a camera. That's like a
super super person move. For one frame
for his body to jump like that it was no
smooth movement there. We know that but
I personally believe it might be if this
is a real video he had coffee figure on
his lip may Allah destroy his lip. Um
and he wiped it off and said okay uh Do
you get it? I I I feel but but it was a
random jump up cuz even if you do that
bro I'll be honest with you like if I
had the coffee stain on my on my lip
I and then I say okay stop filming.
I'm not going to I'm not going to say
okay carry on now and I'm going to go to
the same it's it's very awkward to in
that moment to be that and be like
>> stop cut cut again we're going okay.
You know something? He didn't mention
that you can kind of see when he lifts
the cup up Yeah. it doesn't move. The
liquid doesn't move.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well that's actually It's
not natural.
I want to know what you guys think
though. So let me know what you guys are
finding out. Hopefully you guys download
this video and it just sounded so weird
right? Benjamin Netanyahu shows up at a
coffee shop. He misses his military
briefing. He's not like in a war zone
saying guy like rah rah rallying the
troops because that seemed like it was
too much. The coffee shop seemed like it
was the easiest thing to AI for these
people and that's what they went with.
It doesn't seem like this he's not a lot
guys. This is fake video. Drive Drive
your comments let me know what you
think. He's dead or he's not. Him dying
okay. What what what are you going to
get happy about in the sense of okay may
Allah destroy him let him die. I mean
the the the thing is what's going to
wait for him in the hereafter. So that's
eventually going to happen. He's going
to die. Like Allah says that you know in
the Quran very clearly. You can look
live to whenever you like. You are going
to die. You can be a fortified tower but
my friend this is death is going to
reach you. So we should focus because
people would see death as a punishment.
If that's the case, they'll all get
punished. That's not the case. Death is
a beginning for him. So, better I might
for those people who want him to die,
okay, him dying, what's going to happen?
Like of course we want him like may
Allah destroy him. I want I want him to
get painful death. That's what, you
know. But the punishment starts in the
hereafter where Allah tells us when his
soul is taken. Yes, when Allah says come
out to the wrath of your Lord, his soul
is ripped out from his body. Yes, okay.
And then he's going lifted up to the
heavens and he's called of the most
disgusting names and he's he's this
Allah said in the Quran that his back
will be smite by the
the angels cursing him. Okay? And
nothing but destruction. His grave will
be hellfire inshallah all that kind of
stuff. So, for those who are very
obsessed with his death and this that,
it doesn't change because another
dirtbag is going to come and do the same
thing. So, he's just one person but may
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala destroy him. I
ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to give
him a painful death. I mean. You know,
and then the punishment that's going to
wait in the hereafter. For us to have
trust in that, that is the real
cornerstone. When he dies
and we know what's going to happen
subhanallah on that day. I mean that's
what I would say, you know, if he's dead
or not. I don't know if he's dead or not
but again, you know, there is something
sus going on. Him not going to his
war meetings or whatever it is for that
matter and then
end up in a coffee shop. Bro, you know,
if anything show your face there not
there. Mhm.
Yeah, I mean as Muslims we just also
have to remember to have full faith in
the plan that Allah has. I I think
sometimes we get too worried about all
the issues going on. Like we should
fight these issues and we should stand
against these issues but we shouldn't
think these issues is the never-ending
cycle of what's going to happen, right?
Everyone is going to face their Lord.
Everyone is going to get their
punishment and get their reward. So, at
the end of the day, like what's going to
happen is going to happen and the people
who are going to get punished, they're
going to get punished.
>> Yes. So, as much as we might stress
about all the atrocities going on.
>> a million years. Yeah, doesn't matter.
They're going to have a horrible
hereafter, right? So, we just have to
stay firm and remember that Allah has a
greater plan than any of us. Exactly.
Brothers and sisters, till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.